hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game from the pogchamp
championship semi-finals it's a boy
versus box box and it's again quite the
game so without further ado let's check
it out with the white pieces of oh boy
opens with E for sorry about that and
box box replies with C sexy goes for the
caro-kann defense we have d4 and now d5
and Volvo goes for the advanced
variation of the car account with E 5
and Bishop to f5 now which is our usual
where you want to develop you want to
get your darks light square Bishop out
of the box and then close the setup with
with a six and here there are a lot of
moves you can play you can go for h4g
493 you could go for Knight c3 Bishop e2
Bishop b3 so a whole lot of
possibilities here depending on how what
kind of game you want to play whoever
goes for Bishop to d3 he challenges the
lights for a bishop immediately and the
black is very happy with this so box box
captures with captures captures and
ecigs
and now black is happy since he has all
of his pawns on light squares and he has
a dark square bishop so you can use it
on those dark squares we have Knight to
f3 continuing development and now c5 a
very very very modern idea going for
that striking the center right away even
though it kind of loses a temple but it
is a very often played and also you free
the c6 square for your knight
yeah so here while you could defend it
with c3 or just continuing development
let's say Bishop to e3 boy boy decides
to capture with D captures on c5 with
Bishop captures on c5 and now he goes
for quinta b5 with check checks the King
connects with the bishop and c5 and this
is nothing new this has been played
before Knight to d7 is the usual
response here that blocks check and
defends the bishop however box box goes
for Knight to c6 and this is a new move
so already as of move 8 we have a
completely new game now it's a weird
move as if the blunders the Bishop on c5
now so what character said we have Queen
characters on c5 and now Knight G to e7
continuing development and preparing the
cata Castle so Bishop to g5 Wilbur also
continues development and now look to
see a threatening some
the discoveries so here we have Bobcat
for sunny seven night capture sunny 7
opening up an attack towards the Queen
and again Queen to be 5 with check-box
block set up with rook to c6 and here
well you should let's say just continue
development here Webber goes for Queen
captures on b7 not right away first he
goes for Knight to the b4 attacks the
rook twice now and now you kinda need to
react to this of course you cannot move
the rook as there is this pin going on
so first box box throws in and in
between move he forces the Queen to move
so maybe the rook can wiggle out and
here now you could go for Knight
captures on c6 as it also attacks blacks
Queen or you could try and keep the
tension with Queen a4 but here Webber
goes for Queen captures on b7 and this
is a bit too optimistic because now he
allows this free move Queen to b6 and
now it's not all that clear how the
White Queen will escape from here so
Quinta a7 and now we have castles and
now there are a lot of interesting ideas
on how you could go after the White
Queen so here we have a 4 by Walker he
wants to go for a 5 and now Knight to c8
attacking the Queen
we Quinta a8 and now it's a very
interesting position so even even feel
free to pause the video here and try to
find the best move for black well while
I give you a couple of seconds so for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations on successfully trapping
the Queen and for those who just want to
enjoy the show Queen to c7 is the way to
go you you move the Queen away from the
from the back rank and the next you want
to go Knight to e7 and trap the Queen
and there's no good way to avoid this
since you're already up a piece best of
what you can do is a5 just go after the
rook and then after Knights the e7 you
capture here you don't get to capture
blacks Queen because black has Queen
captures on e5 with the check but after
the King moves you can pick up the Queen
and you will of course be much better so
this was the way to go however voxbox
goes for Queen to h4 it's a similar idea
although not as potent and
you're again threatening Knights the e7
and you are going for the night here so
here we have a five verbal just
continues the attack on the rook and now
Knight to e7 and here again a very
interesting position where boy boy can
save the queen with queen to a7 but he
decides to give it up with Queen
captures and f8 we've we have reached
the position from the thumbnail we have
King captures only move and now a
captures and b6 we have Queen captures
and before grabbing that night and now
after all is said and done Volvo has two
rooks for a queen now which is still not
not all that great as his King is still
in the center and you still have to
mobilize your rooks
so here we have castles now the
autoroute can enter the game as well and
here what you want to do is eliminate
this pawn this is a very dangerous
passport and you want to get rid of it
as soon as possible however box box goes
for Queen capture son beat you first
he puts pressure on this rook and the
pawn however allows rook captures on a6
now the rook frees itself and also
defends the b6 pawn and now Knight to c8
he goes after the b6 pawn but this again
doesn't doesn't do all that well for
black so again feel free to pause the
video and try to take advantage of this
move while I give you a couple of
seconds
so for those who were able to do it
congratulations on picking up the night
and for those who who just want to enjoy
the show its rook to e8 there's no way
for you to save the night well you could
play something like Queen captures and
c2 but then b7 just wins the game on the
spot so here Queen captures and b6 had
to be played and now we're we just grabs
the night as well so rook captures on c8
with check King g7 and now Knight to e2
preparing to bring the other rook inter
game so Queen a six and now comes Luke
the c3 as the rook is under attack so
rook to c3 and now
d4 we have worked a b3 and now f6 box
box tries to eliminate the strong a5
pawn and try to get some counter play so
he captures on f6 with check King
captures now and not pawn captures he
wants to keep this pawn in the center so
he can start
in the two central pawns and now rook F
the b1 with ideas of maybe going rogue
b6 and maybe the knight can find its way
to maybe put pressure on the e6 pawn so
Queen a5 attacking the knight and now
Knights the efore with check King to g6
and now g3 preparing King G to h4 h5 and
so on here we have Queen to f5 putting
pressure on the night and now Knight to
d6 again attacking the Queen Queen
captures on c2 and now things are a
little bit different because now box box
also creates a pass to D pawn and here
what boy plays King to g2 which is now a
mistake and well for the further not for
the last time but again feel free to
pause the video and take advantage of
King to g2 while I give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on picking
off the night this time and for those of
you just wanna enjoy the show its Queen
to c6 check this check checks the king
and of course picks up the night however
box box didn't go for this he went for
the pawn push immediately thinking that
okay I have d2 d1 and Vogel has to give
up a row better to capture a rogue than
a knight however Knights the e4 guards
the d 2 square so d2 and here well you
can play Knight to c3 which guards the
d1 pawn probably whatever I thought that
it would be too much of a commitment to
commit to pieces to guarding the pawn so
instead he eliminates the D DuPont gives
up the night Queen captures on d2 and
now rook 3 to be to pushing back the
Queen and now it's Queen against two
rooks and it's not gonna be easy for for
either side so Queen to d5 with check f3
now blocking and E 5 now a box box
starts to advance his EEP on we have
looked the b6 check kink the f5 now and
King to f7 is a bit more a bit more safe
however it's also not very pleasant
maybe you will be able to easily
checkmate the black king so in a rapid
game King to f5 does seem a bit safer
however you are now very very close to
White's pawns wow those are weird
arrows and whatever of gore of course
goes for the king so g4 with check we
have King to g5 and now for the last and
final time in this video feel free to
pause the video and win the game for
white while I give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on
spotting the the correct mating web and
for those of you who just wanna enjoy
show its king to g3 this is what we were
played and now there is no defense
against h4 now you could try a lot of
things here to me prolong the game or or
or to defend however a box book just
played h5 he wanted to play h4 to push
back the white king however here Weber
just played h4 and this is now checkmate
since the rug cuts off the king from the
6th rank and the pawns and King don't
allow the black king to go anywhere so
this is checkmate and it doesn't even
matter if you go for the absolute best
defense here which is g6 it still it
still ends in like eater mate or severe
material loss h4 check King age 6 and
now you could just go rook to b7 with
the threat of g5 check King h5 and rook
captures on h7 with checkmate so black
would have to prevent this guard upon
here but now rook eise Evan I'm just
preparing to bring the other rook into
the game and here black is basically
without him whatever you play it's just
terrible let's see g5 white white can
block it with h5 it's not a problem look
the b6 would win the game so let's say
block at Queen b8 but now again rugby -
b7 again threating mate in one
so the Queen has the block and now
finally rule b6 check Queen has to block
with let's say queen g6 and now you just
pick it up and that's it rogue b7 and
this is now it will be checkmate so it
doesn't matter that bogus box allowed
mate in one
it's still completely lost even if
played to perfection so that's a game
one of their semi-final match we're also
gonna show game 2 as it's quite
interesting and and a very short one
alright so that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank a base
seller Frank Truslow bala Morgana
Subramanian Baracus not Carney and even
Lubitsch's for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon probably with the second game
of their semi-final match so I think
y'all I will see soon and have an
excellent rest of your Friday